good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Wednesday it is hump day don't
forget to hump someone you love and
speaking of humping people that I love
it's a girl that I love it's Shak hey L
de screw Lou de
L hello tury lho tury
L
for Doris welcome toaster to this show
hope hopefully the people who wrote this
jingle are in litigious no
so yeah we'll get into it on
Friday I just want to say about that
song that is pervasive in the Grinch
movies it's always what the who's are
carolling and we know the who's are
always carolling and it's not on the
soundtrack disgusting I kind of feel
like it's ripe for recording nobody
really owns it maybe y girls it's kind
of like a legal gray area is that what
you're saying it's a legal it's a murky
it's a jingle it's it's something that's
in the zis that nobody
owns I absolutely love that I feel like
there are songs like that like who
owns Old
McDonald somebody for sure probably
Fisher Price on if I had to guess no
they own uh that new song that
everyone's talking about you know what's
the song The Animals play the animals
play the anim animal play all day
there's this mat the monkey play there's
this mat that like everybody it's viral
if you have a baby right now I didn't
have it for Harry but then I saw that
gir is posting it so I got it and
Charlie loves it and it will it can keep
transitioning as babies get older and it
has original music on it it's about 25
minutes of music songs you've never
heard before but they will get inside
your head and and they will not leave
your head well let me say that I do love
my job more than anything but if I had
to be doing something else I would want
to be in the music department of like a
big children's company whether that's
like Hasbro fish your price I'm not
particular I feel like the collaborative
process is amazing in those companies
and I think we you know we would be
doing really important work together no
you would be very good at that I do feel
as though that's your calling that
you've missed and instead you're sitting
here with your girl yeah or I would be
one of those um you know music class for
kids where they have like a guitar
player a singer and then like somebody
handing out scarves I would be one of
those oh yeah if you didn't quite make
it at Hasbro and they said that would be
the fallback I feel like that's like the
most fun but also torturous job yeah
it's a lot of work I feel like for me my
missed calling was being a bot Mitzvah
dance motivator I completely agree when
we were watching your Bot Mitzvah video
on family vacation now I'm not you know
my joints are old and creaky crey but at
a at a point in my life like that was my
calling I can I can get the crowd moving
and going let me ask you a question cuz
I haven't been to a basm mitvah in many
many years but I know in the day and age
we grew up in when you did the Bat
Mitzvah circuits in seventh and eighth
grade every B Mitzvah worth it salt had
a DJ with a bunch of motivators they
were like these young kind of 20-some
very fit boys and girls wearing all
black whose job it was to like hype up
the crowd get the you know the conga
line started it was kind of a thankless
job is that still part of bmva trend
culture I don't know why it wouldn't be
but please let us know in the comments
are the motivators still employed or
have they been taken over by AI yeah I
don't know why I just feel like it's a
thing of the past I hope it's
not but also I would love a documentary
on that cuz I I I know now like those
20s something were like drunk and they
were like [__] uncles and cousins and
stuff at bot mitz I was like I know that
now but back then I didn't know like I
think there was an an underbelly like a
sub cult culture of the Bas mvah
motivational dancers and what was going
what was really what was the real party
yeah did you say we're doing drugs no no
no no that's the sort of thing that will
get you fired we won't tolerate that
here I actually think even sneaking
alcohol like would be a you know demerit
but it's the kind of job that literally
requires drugs and alcohol for sure but
not if you're natural at it like for me
I wouldn't need drugs and alcohol which
is why it's my calling for me like the
only way I would survive even one B
Mitzvah is with like a massive amounts
of drugs and alcohol like I would need
Aderall cocaine like it's hours and
hours of dancing B Mitzvah are like 5
hours that's insane I feel like maybe
there are different levels of DJ
companies and maybe the most elite have
those who are most naturally gifted and
they don't need performance-enhancing
substances and maybe like the Lesser
tiers it's like cracked out motivators
cracked DJ cracked out DJ crack d
C that would be the name of your company
that employs like a bunch of you know um
like Aderall riddled teens it would be
called CIO
Productions fine only because not that
that that that's the type of environment
you would Harbor but only because it's a
great name yeah yeah and then I would
have to live up to the name yeah yeah I
know
like are you excited for like that part
of your life like when you're kids are
grown and like they're doing the bomit F
like you obviously go as an adult and
the kids go for like the kids but you go
cuz you're friends with the parents like
it's kind of like it's the two Journeys
in life you know you're either a guest
of the bar mitzah boy or the bar mitzah
boy's parents yeah because otherwise you
don't go to Bar Mitzvah it's just like I
haven't been to a bar mitzvah in since
Margo no you're either 12 or 40 like
that's it so yeah it's it seems like a
ball like getting to be at a party all
dressed up and that your kids are there
too but it's definitely like a diff a
next chapter yeah you know so it's like
oh I guess I'll be
older wiser yeah 40s yeah
40s so we've got a great show today
let's do a little housekeeping you know
it's Wednesday which is a huge day here
at the toast normally we would do our
deer toasters Our advice segment that we
literally got over like 700 submissions
last week like people are desperate for
for dead serious you always say we don't
get any I did Hound people last week
being like where the hell are you and
they showed up so we'll do that but
we're going to do it tomorrow because
last night was the premier of Vanner
pump rules we're going to do a little TV
recap even though there's literally
nothing to say no we will talk about it
at the end of today's episode we'll do
uh we'll bring back the TV Recaps
because Vander pump rules is on so
housekeeping will go as such Wednesday
VOR pump rolls Thursday deer toasters
Friday weenie of the week and Queenie
and Queenie can only be negative 30 I
can but we have to try at least and you
know another week has gone by where I
have a million candidates for weenie of
the week and I can't scrouge up one
measly person for Queenie of the week
well maybe today your Queenie will come
through Perhaps Perhaps not we have
great stories I don't know for sure
because I did not choose them but I know
that there was a new episode of new
heights yes I actually don't know if
anything they said made it to Fast Five
after so there they really like didn't
say anything watch oh here's you know Mr
Kelsey father's nickname for taylored
yeah like they're really and it turns
out to be like Tay no I just want to say
we got so much on Sunday it's like and
we can't complain but I was kind of for
me like the new episode of new heights
like what would come from it was a life
raft to get through the week and now
that I'm here like I'm drowning there
was nothing there was nothing and I
think their strategy is to talk about it
on the show but not in a way where
they're actually saying anything because
they don't want to actually divulge too
much so people are picking up scraps
Jason calls Taylor a part of the family
as engagement looms like right and he
literally didn't he just said the family
mom dad T yeah or he probably said like
Chief's family in the sweet yeah friend
friends and
family so so that was tough but and I
sent you this story but I respect that
they still get on the Pod they still do
their job they don't ignore it they
address it but I also respect that they
give us nothing it's an art it really is
an art to talk about something without
saying anything word salad energy word
salad yummy yummy but the key to a word
salad is to not let people know that it
is a word salad and you only realize
after when you eaten it like hey oh I
had a salad and I do think people
watched the episode and like felt like
they got stuff and they felt fulfilled
even though it's you know they're
literally being gaslit because there was
nothing in the episode so you're right
it was a successful word salad because
sometimes when you're there's nothing
more painful than listening to an
obvious word salad that's a jumble of
words that don't lead anywhere agreed
that's a failed word salad we all know
who we're talking
about I literally don't know were your
headphones not plugged in again no they
were I just plugged my my computer into
charge oh my God getting yelled at I
don't know who you were just like
suddenly queen of word
salads Olivia no no that's that's rude
is it I feel like Olivia would agree
she's quite verbose yeah she's verbose
she's salad likee but her salad has
protein and and cheese and things yes
but there's a lot of lettuce there is
there is okay who's the queen of word
salad that's so funny that you don't
have the same Association of a word
salad you going to say Taylor Taylor who
Swift no yeah no I I literally don't
know who you're talking about really is
it me no oh my God you're not thinking
broadly enough think in like a more
Global context on a very big
stage kamla Harris oh I was literally
like I by it's not really like a global
stage but I guess yeah yeah she does
give word salad energy but you know at
at some point like the Master Chef of a
word salad except it's not she's the
Gordon she's the Gordon Ramsay for sure
yeah but like she's botching but Jackie
she also has like a team of people who
wrote who created chopped the salads for
her that's even scarier because her word
salads are not successful word salads in
the sense that you didn't you know
you're eating a salad yeah yeah yeah but
wait all I was trying to say was about
the how we gotten this word salad train
the
stories while New Heights word salad
there is y kind of there is a story
today that at least for me might be the
most important thing we'll ever discuss
here on the toast okay is it one of the
one that you sent me yes oh actually you
sent me like three sort of so well at
first I was sending you like things that
I thought you would enjoy I wasn't
suggesting but then I sent you a story
from People magazine regarding tar elusa
yeah yeah yeah yeah do you want that to
be the first one I actually think it is
that important like dead seriously and
for those who might be new here this is
a part of toast lore this is it is a
running like joke but it's not a joke to
me like to me it's very
serious it is something I haven't
stopped thinking about since 2016 and I
haven't stopped talking about since 2016
and for the first time ever we have an
update that's why you stay committed to
the things that you need answers for
yeah okay so let's get into the stories
without further Ado well we're already
talking about them so I don't want to
like double dip okay wait let me think
what did like what did I want to share I
had steak for dinner I saw ex Shapiro
like let me think let me think I guess I
could share that I'm still sick but my
voice has changed and I think it's like
a nice voice um and I'm in the process
of like weaning from breastfeeding so
I'm just like in pain and it's like it's
such a slow process and I think I might
have like skipped a step so I'm I'm
suffering I didn't know that that's kind
of like a big deal why didn't you share
that I thought I did you were like have
been saying that you're going to do it
but not that you're starting it it takes
weeks if you want to do it right so I'm
probably like two weeks away from being
done but this is kind of a a a step
backwards because I feel like I should
have pumped midday yesterday and I
skipped it but I literally didn't have
the time when was I supposed to pump do
you need me to fly down and suck out you
have a little you have a little what's
it called block no uh clog and I think
I've said this on the toes before but
the thing about clogs is in the years
since I've had Harry and Charlie like
science on clogs has completely changed
like it used to be you know put heat on
it yes because they thought it was an
actual clog and now they're like no it's
a swelling so put cold on it like the
actual exact opposite like and now they
say like take Advil and put cold whereas
before it was like by the way do you do
cabbage so I never did cabbage before
but I've heard that it really works and
I'm going to be getting some cabbage
today all my girly friends like who have
they were talking about it the other day
like everybody does cabbage it's like
the thing you just do it like it works
instantly
yeah for your friends did they
breastfeed at all yes but they want it
to be done yes cuz some people who don't
want to breastfeed at all like the week
that they give birth they do cabbage so
that their milk doesn't come in or they
do like ice CS oh maybe there might have
been someone in the group who did that
too but I know it was like a mixed bag
of girlies when it came to their breasts
aren't we all a mixed bag of girlies
when it comes to our breasts a ain't
that the truth so I'm going to do
cabbage and also I what's working out
for me is when you're sick your supply
lessons and usually when I'm sick and
breastfeeding I don't take medication
because those medications are drying to
dry out your nostrils but they also dry
out your breasts but now I can take that
medication
intentionally to dry out it's not
working that's fabulous before we dve in
there was something I wanted to do I
wanted to use my platform for good oo so
Jackie and I have started like this
little campaign just you know in our
community we really think that our older
sister Olivia should get a dog and not
just any dog like her and her husband
have spoken about getting like a bernes
mountain
dog 's only one breed that we really
would consider and I think that we
should use our platform for good and I
think we should start you know an
initiative to anyone who's like a dog
parent and also like Olivia has two kids
like she has a lot going on it's not
like you know she doesn't want a dog for
no reason like she's a lot going on but
I think like everybody should really
kind of like share their stories about
how the dog enhanced their life and how
their kids love the dog so much and
maybe like drop a comment on YouTube or
send aivia message like I just think the
power of the Chast can convince her I
don't think so she's so stubborn we're
all so stubborn I don't know what you're
talking about I'm not stubborn you're
stubborn the Satchel is stubborn who do
you think is the most stubborn in the
family I don't think you're stubborn by
the way you don't no you're a lot of
things but you're not
stubborn no I'm kidding you're a lot of
things you know beautiful kind caring
generous yeah I don't think I'm super
stubborn but sometimes I can
be I don't know yeah anyway anyways
who's the most stubborn Satchel mhm but
you're pretty bad too really I feel like
I'm so open to like I I acknowledge my
stubbornness but you never like and I
know that I'm stubborn against something
but in a year from now like I know I'll
say like why can't you just do it not in
a year from now like what like what I
feel like I've gotten so good like if I
told you something that you would love
right now you don't go and do it you
don't trust tell me what have I to do
maybe a reason like like you
were what like you were stubborn against
beef
stew okay fine I'll give you that I'm
stubborn against food I have like a food
thing I have issues with like certain
foods that's to me like a biological
fine I'll accept that but when I say
tury you're going to love this like can
you just trust your
girl I feel like I do trust you I tried
your beef
too like what more do you want for me
puzzled it what more do you want for me
I ate the beef stew and I loved it and I
said I was wrong like my God is that is
that what a stubborn person would do no
no I'm not asking that I'm asking for
the next recommendation I give you that
you try it at once not at
last I feel like the first opportunity I
had to try beef stew I did but after
make my own after poo and I just want to
say I didn't poo poo beef stew I PE poo
pooed just like the frequency in which
we were talking about beef stew but the
thing is we're doing important work like
I get tagged in beef stews all the time
same people are using beef stew to up
their supply people are using beef stew
to get pregnant it's a very nourishing
food and it's important that we do that
toour of work here tury should I make
beef stew for my book club yes I'll send
you the
real you have to follow the real I I
I've pretty much like dead set on like
catering actually I met a uh dm with the
toaster yesterday who's like a kosher
chef and she's like let me let me just
like cook it and like drop it off of
your house that sounds amazing or Ben
could make the beef stew because he
helped me and he knows the stew yeah I
helped you too and I could just watch
our patreon Vlog at patreon.com theast
you could if I wanted to I could it's a
good Vlog you should all watch it I also
wanted to update everyone on something
that like I feel for so many months I
was talking about endlessly and then I
just kind of stopped talking about it my
eye
twitch and I do want everyone to know
like it is still omnipresent like
extremely when we went away on vacation
it it went away a little bit but not so
much and it's definitely lessened but I
still have an eye twitch same ey same
area same
everything sad and like that's what I'm
living with yeah sad sad sad when I
climb into bed I start feeling sad
suddenly I miss my mom and my dad
without
Nintendo right right and this is just a
great reminder that this podcast is
hosted by not one but two female authors
Jackie rhen absolutely just truly like
chilling groundbreaking and borderline
heartbreaking children's book called the
camper and the counselor you can get it
on Amazon or wherever you get your books
it's called the camper and the counselor
by jackan as actually Jackie kind of
weird you didn't use your government
name on the cover well I I used my known
name so much smarter but like it's just
kind of crazy I know but it was
definitely a chice you used your stage
name yeah it's my stage name I didn't
use my married name either I went with
the name that like the people know me by
and my book is also by my stage name um
both my stage names girl with no job the
crazy beautiful life of an Instagram
thirst monster it's a it's an
autobiography it's 240 Pages it's really
a light read people are saying it's kind
of their you know favorite book of the
past 10 years that's just what people
are saying and you can also get it on
Amazon again it's called girl with no
job by Claudia asre I think you'd enjoy
both of those you know something for
everyone in your life I feel like not
enough people know that we're authors no
I agree and you know not to I just feel
like I'm always bringing up tanks like
wherever I am but she's kind of like
like I'm inspired by her and I was
watching her stories and I realized like
she's always talking about her book and
I'm like I need to talk about my book
more like I always I forget that I'm a
published author I and tins helped me
see that in myself you know I think the
same thing like I'll see the book on the
shelf and I'm like I need to talk about
this book more no I'll see the book on
the shelf and I'll be like things I did
that things I did that I actually In My
Time Hop like I see all the stuff for
pictures of like getting the book ready
like a year I was picking out the size I
had like pictures of like a bunch of
different books so it's all very
exciting
the difference a year can make we're
women in comedy we're women in
podcasting we're women in publishing
we've been women in publishing though on
both sides this podcast is like an
episode of younger as readers and as
authors yeah I also think like going
back to a conversation from 30 minutes
ago jobs like we could do I actually
people ask me all the time like if you
weren't doing this what would you do and
I always have like jokey answers but I
actually do think I would really enjoy
working at like a Reese's book club or
like a Publishing House and being like
something like maybe a taste maker in
the in the literary Arts yeah I think I
could be a good reader like read books
and recommend them or decide if we want
to publish them or decide if they're
going to be the book of the month you
would be like the junk pile coordinator
at a Publishing House what is
that didn't you watch younger they have
a junk pile where like all these
manuscripts end up either people send
them in or they came from someone else
and every now and then like you'll find
like a diamond in the in the junk stack
but nobody wants to touch the junk stack
so it's literally just like this big
pile in the corner of the office office
yeah no that's what Dana's calling is
that she missed cuz she reads really
quickly she has really great taste and
that's her calling I love that I'm glad
that she has a book club podcast where
she can at least Channel some Flex
Channel some of that but it's sad when
people miss their calling just like you
and I bringing it back to the top of the
show I do feel like I miss my calling
dead seriously like when it comes to
having a career in music it is my dream
I really need to release some more music
even though like you know did you see
Kate Hudson released a song I did and
I'm so glad she brought that up because
like a fun fact about Kate Hudson she
reminds me a lot um of gwenneth paltro
in the sense that like they're both
known for being actors however they both
have amazing singing voices and I
believe they were both unly so that's
how I discovered that they both sing and
I think that was like the one
opportunity they got to like do both
things that they love and I've always
known that she's saying there's actually
a viral video of her singing I think the
national anthem or something people are
always shocked to find out she has an
amazing voice and I think she finally
was just like [__] it what if I just
released a song yeah and it's like a Bop
yeah I love it I love that for her she
didn't like do like major promo for it I
think it's actually just truly a passion
project and I think her man's is like a
music producer so they probably just
like made it in the house classic stuff
that's a dream yeah being married to a
music producer who has like a studio in
the house that you can use like to make
music but also record your podcast also
another like Jackie
Shimmel like like that is probably like
I'm not a jealous person actually I am
but there are a few things like in life
that make me really really jealous and
Jackie shimo being married to like a
very successful music producer who has a
studio in his own house that then like
he helps her like soundproof her Studio
like like that's a dream and then he's
also responsible I think he wrote
like I forget which One Direction song
it was but like a really good one I live
for you I long for you Olivia one of
those shouldn't it be called Jackie
then
wow then maybe it wasn't that I think it
was um she be my queen since we were 16
we want the same dream just look it up
dreams all right this is more fun I
would say it's just more fun to like
kind of scroll through the category
because I remember I was like like
singing that song once on Instagram
she's like by the way did you know my
husband did this song I'm like no it was
like the craziest thing I ever learned
like that to me like that's something to
be jealous of and I think being jealous
is okay as long as it's something worthy
you know yeah and as long as you don't
act in an nefarious way I'm not going to
steal her husband we're like yeah yeah
as long as it doesn't drive you to do
bad things yeah no I would never I would
never you're jealous of I was just
saying yesterday and like I'm jealous of
Shannon's
productivity oh I'm jealous of Shannon's
house I'm jealous of yeah just Shannon's
get up I'm jealous that Shannon wakes up
at the time she wakes up naturally and
starts your day and has a coffee like if
I could get up at that time I could get
so much more done I guess it just depend
like I'm actually jealous of like a lot
of things in Shannon's life in
particular like I'm jealous of her body
I'm jealous of her house I'm jealous of
her clothes I'm jealous of her sense of
style like it's one thing to be able to
buy nice things but it's another thing
to like style put them together yeah I'm
yeah but but Shannon's also like when
you meet her I actually understand why
people maybe like when meet Shannon
before they meet her and like dislike
her cuz she's there's so much in her
life that's to be envious of but then
you meet her and like you can't help but
be truly happy for her and like realize
she has all these things cuz she
deserves them you know and she like
earned them totally G hate hate her yeah
great anything else jealous of today oh
my God today I don't know but in general
yes like I'm a I'm a very I'm constant I
need that's something I need to work on
actually not to keep bringing up tinks
but when we were together she was like
we were having a really deep
conversation and she was like what's
like your least favorite part of
yourself and I was like my thighs and
she was like no no no like personal legs
yeah by the way I was I was making a
joke oh she was she was like personality
wise and I was like I really am like a
jealous person and it's like a really
poor quality and she was like yeah
should fix that I feel like yes you
could fix that or I think if you're
honest about it yeah it becomes like a
funny thing and it's not so
dark so true but I feel like people who
Harbor jealousy and like just act like
don't vocalize it don't make a joke
about it and just like act out it's so
out of jealousy like that's Green With
Envy but being like you could turn your
jealousy into like
complimentary yeah yeah yeah and there's
no there are few things that like if
you're jealous of someone having why not
go and get them for yourself so true of
course not a music producer husband but
that specific one I guess I could turn
my alarm on at 6:00 a.m. and clean my
closet right there are certain things
like within your grasp
right my part feels off it's like
bothering me looks but good thanks
girlly okay I do feel now I feel it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by drizzly picture this nightmare
scenario you're hosting friends for the
big game it's neck and- neck in the
fourth quarter and suddenly you realize
you're out of drinks
boo you start to sweat your friends
start to turn on you you're forced to go
on a last-second drink run and you end
up missing the game-winning touchdown
while in line terrifying isn't it well
luckily you can avoid the drama with
drizzly the go-to app for drink delivery
with drizzly you can shop a huge
selection of beer wine and spirits and
then get them delivered right to your
watch party you can also compare prices
across multiple stores in your area you
can find the best deals on Game Day
drinks and get back to armchair
quarterbacking from you guessed it your
armchair download the drizzly app to get
drizzly or go to drizzle.com that's d r
Iz l.com today you must be over 21 it's
not available in all locations and I
want to say probably one of my favorite
things about drizzly is that in certain
areas you can get sprit Society on
drizzly so your crush and spritzes or
whatever it is that you're drinking this
actually no it's next weekend excuse me
for the big game make sure to have
drizly downloaded on your phone like
don't be irresponsible things can you
know sometimes you you you miscalculated
how many drinks you were to need you're
human it's fine like you were doing a
lot have the drizzly app you can
download it d r i z l y you can also go
to drizly.com you must be over 21 it is
not available in all locations download
the drizzly app or go to drizly.com d r
i z l y.com today must be over 21 not
available in all locations today's
episode is also brought to you by the
new Lionsgate movie scrambled so
scrambled is a heartfelt yet hilarious
journey of self-discovery and self-love
it's written directed and stars Leah
mckendrick who is quote among Indie
wire's top female filmmakers to watch
this year super excited about this new
Lionsgate movie It's called scrambled
and I feel like it's really for the
toasters I think it's kind of a really
relatable Journey that the character is
going through um perhaps one that you've
gone through or you're currently going
through that journey of like being
single not minding so much but knowing
your biological clock is ticking and
like wanting you know maybe wanting kids
one day not being so sure feeling like
you have to grow up overnight that's
exactly what happens in this movie so
the quintessential Eternal bridesmaid
Nelly Robinson who's played by leam
mckendrick is constantly finding herself
between weddings baby showers and bad
dates so when she begins to feel like
the clock is ticking she is faced with
Bleak romantic prospects Nelly decides
to freeze her eggs setting her on an
empowering Journey To A Brave New World
where she ultimately discovers the one
she's looking for might just be herself
film threat sells says it's brilliant
storytelling you can learn more watch
the trailer at lionsgate.com
scrambled the trailer will give you
chills also it has my favorite song in
it uh Love Myself by haly Steinfeld
which is like such a good song like and
I feel like it's emblematic of the theme
of the movie that's a song that you
should have recorded okay I'm so glad
you brought that up I want to talk about
that in one second great the movie
scrambled is in theaters February 2nd it
is rated R grab your gal Pals excuse me
go by yourself February 2nd Lionsgate
movie scrambled is in theaters February
2nd rated R um it's so funny that you
said that that's the song I should have
recorded both times when I I for those
who maybe don't know I released two
Grammy Award uh winning songs and but at
the very beginning of the creative
process of both of those songs with the
producers and the songwriters the song
that I cited like that I wanted it to be
like message wise soundwise Melody wise
was Love Myself by haly Steinfeld
totally and then the other song that you
should should have written is Brave by
Jesse
J uh actually you should have written
that song because I don't even know that
song no no if you listen to it will you
listen to it
quickly uh have we learned nothing for
Friday we can't be playing songs on this
podcast anymore frick frack but anyways
the song is like one of my favorite
songs it's called Brave by Jesse J by
the way shout out to Jesse J she's one
of my favorite people on the planet
she's so like criminally underrated
she's so criminally talented like she's
the best singer ever she's such a great
songwriter for herself and for other
people and now she's literally from what
I see on Instagram the most amazing mom
like nobody is happier to be a mom I
just love watching people who like love
motherhood and she I love her it's also
fun to watch someone who like motherhood
didn't come easy to and who wanted it
for so long and I think I heard her say
in an interview on she kind of came to
terms with like the fact that that was
not going to be her future um so
somebody who wanted it so bad and then
got it like it's it's beautiful to watch
it really is she's a fun follow and I
want new music from Jesse J I agreed but
also like enjoy your life true not me
putting pressure on a new Mama it's so
true M get her
no get her our first
story huge news tar elmusa finally tells
his version of the gun incident that
ended his marriage to Christina Hall so
tar El Musa has his Memoirs coming out
called Memoirs of a
tar what is it called actually flip your
life how to find opportunity God enough
with flip how to find opportunity in
distress in real estate business and
life of course it had to be flip your
life but I just feel like it could have
been Memoirs of a flipper no it really
should have been Memoirs of aaric
Memoirs of AAR he's telling his side of
the story of the 2016 incident involving
a gun that led to their divorce so when
the pair split became public in December
it was revealed that they'd actually
secretly separated 7 months earlier
during an altercation in which tar fled
into a nature area with a pistol after
what he called a blowup fight with
Christina this was in 2016 let me say
like why this has such historical
significance to me I obviously like
during 2016 like I was really involved
in HGTV culture like obviously I stay I
came for chip and Joe stayed for chip
and Joe and then I found you know some
other couples and Christina and Tark
were like this lowbudget West Coast
version they had the worst style their
show was horrible but like they were so
basic like and it was just it was
interesting to watch them try to be chip
and Joe when like they never were going
to be chip and Joe ever in their lives
like they didn't have one creative bone
in their body all of their houses look
the same white subway tile and they were
just like this weird couple and I just
started to like follow them and stuff
and then like this story comes out that
there's this crazy altercation at their
house tar has fled the home they live in
the mountains or like there's a mountain
range behind their house he F flees to
the mountain with a gun the kids and the
wife are in the house there's like a
helicopter looking for him it was a
crazy story and then nobody ever talked
about it ever again and I was like wait
they ended up getting divorced a few
months later but then the show went on
as like you know co-parenting flipping
and flopping and it was just like are we
never going to talk about the gun and
the mountains and it has been years of
waiting for an answer and now we have
one and
honestly there's two sides to every
story and there always are so Christina
called 911 and police flooded the park
as as quickly as it devolved it was over
the incident and their marriage in the
book he writes that after a heated
argument he quote went out to our
backyard in your Belinda and hopped over
the fence on that much the ex's agree
but his explanation as to why differs he
says rather than fleeing he was craving
exercise and wanted to scout the trails
near the house after having recently
purchased some new mountain bikes the
neighboring Chino Hill State Park is a
habitat for wildlife including Mountain
lines and bobcats so he brought along
what he calls an insurance policy a 38
caliber pistol he says he'd received his
California concealed carry license a few
weeks prior when a helicopter appeared
overhead he recalls he thought there was
an emergency possibly a wildfire but he
quickly realized it was for him he said
a police officer leaned out of the
helicopter pointing a rifle at me dust
swirled around me from the spin of the
blades and a loudspeaker crackled get
your hands in the air more police in
off-road vehicle swarmed the officer in
the helicopter miraculously recognized
him I heard an officer shout tar I
screamed back yes I'm the from TV what
are you guys doing they lowered their
weapons I feel like the police officer
probably got his name from the wife who
called the police yeah not because he
was a big HGTV fan yeah they recognized
you cuz you were the person they were
looking for they recognized you because
you had a gun they recognized you from
the wanted
poster they recognized you from the
pictures your wife sent of You by the
way literally tar is me if I ever storm
to the mountains with a gun no you tar
is you if you're ever under arrest they
recognize me oh but but they take a mug
shot
[Music]
Paparazzi wait I just want to say I
don't believe a word of tx's like out of
T's mouth so convenient first of all you
hop the fence like you only hop a fence
when you're in the heat of a moment
obviously something happened at the
house there was like a something
escalated and he probably wanted to like
blow off some team maybe he did bring
the gun for wildlife that's possible but
him acting like he was going to get
exercise to you know look for some
Trails for his new mountain bike but he
also just happened to like get into a
fight with his wife like it just makes
no sense like sorry well maybe he was
like planning on looking for trails and
he was like had in the back of his man
okay I'll do that later but then he got
into a fight with his wife and he was
like it's a good time to look for
Trails I just want to say I like to
believe people and I don't and whether
or not this is true it's it's an amazing
explanation because now oh that's so
funny I completely disagree it's so
stupid I feel like the word exercise is
a
little juv no it's like okay maybe that
word it can mean a lot of things if if
he had said like just to blow off some
steam but like to use the word blow off
some steam and then have a gun on you is
a little scary so I'm sure the editor
said we'll say exercise yeah yeah but if
that's the case he wanted to just like
get out get into nature blow off steam
really and brought his gun for the
Wildlife like so I do want to say I
believe that he brought his gun for the
Wildlife like I actually do believe that
California has like coyotes and [__]
like I believe that part of the story I
do think there are nuggets of truth but
him saying that he left the house for
any other reason than the fact that he
was angry he got into a fight with his
wife and he just wanted to blow up see
like is a lie who hops offense well so
he's saying he got into a fight with his
wife and he was craving exercise due to
maybe the fight with his wife like it's
just a milder way of saying what you're
saying it's a very convenient it's it's
a manipulation of language yeah but it's
a good one I like I have respect for
this where's chis where's Memoirs of a
Christina I need to hear her side of the
story she's never spoken out all she did
was call the police cuz her husband
stormed off angry with a gun I feel like
if this is wildly untrue she'll find a
way to tell the other side of the story
but it's the father of her children
they've moved pass it she's married
twice over now like maybe she'll be like
oh tar also like really went through it
after this like everybody was team
Christina cuz T's in the mountains with
a gun and he like drank himself silly he
was said he was living in yeah he um he
talks about the aftermath of the split
as physical and emotional hell and
rights of hiding out on his boat
drinking himself unconscious and going
through extreme withdrawal from the
testosterone he'd been taking until
friends stepped in to get him to a rehab
facility he said in the wake of this the
world testosterone with yeah that comes
up again um when he talks about it he
said I hold nothing against Christina I
understand why she did what she did we
had a lot of hard years through my
sicknesses and my mental health
struggles from the
testosterone so
testosterone abuse is maybe I didn't
know you could abuse testosterone maybe
he has um clearly clearly have to read
the book to understand his struggles
with testosterone like this is just one
he probably references it throughout the
book but that is like I know men take
testosterone to like Jack up to it's
like a really good thing for their
health and as far as I know it's not
addictive so I don't know how you
can no I mean I have no idea I'm or
maybe he has like naturally low levels
of testosterone so he has to take more
and then I don't know I have no idea I'm
not even going to start to think about
like or speculate on how you can po like
deal with testosterone but if you're
having
withdrawals excuse me what he had
testosterone with drls leave me alone
with
DRS I'm a phonetic
it also is an extremely hard word to say
like withdrawals is how I say it I think
on redheads I said the word drawers no
we had this conversation on the toast
jacket about drawers okay like about how
it's like unies a cabinet for sure so I
just want to let you know like
withdrawal falls under the category of
draw so you make like it's redundant to
make fun of
me okay it's
redundant I can't lie I don't feel like
an overwhelming sense of
peace like I thought I might after you
know finally getting a followup after
could never give you peace turty no I do
feel more confused than ever I feel
like honestly now I feel less at peace I
want to hear from
Christina but you're right Christina and
him like are co-parenting there are some
lines you don't cross let him tell his
like silly little story and his silly
little Memoir that no one's going to
read and I think Christina probably
holds on to the fact that people won't
believe it and I also feel like for you
tury this story is such a core part of
the makeup of tury it's so it's so that
no matter what he says like you can't
let it go who would you be without this
story no I have so much riding on this
particular story so alls that to say I
stand with Christina yeah and everyone
did but it's T's turn to tell his story
T's basically saying me they should have
called the book T's turn no we could
have come up with such a better name
than what was it Flip or Flop flip your
life yeah I guess he's trying to be like
you know Macho investor men like it's
trying to be like a business book so
it's not it's not really Memoir it's
more like it'll probably fall under the
advice howto miscellaneous colum how to
flip your life right I think it should
have be
called Misa Musa T El Musa oh my God I
love Perfection I was thinking taring
carav
business what do you think I think
that's really strong I think so too drop
a comment what would you have named
Taral musa's howto mem
are and also maybe maybe you should have
called it Musa Vibes
only
love also just like another important
fact that I think we absolutely have to
bring up here Jackie and I have met tar
Al Musa at the LAX airport we did he was
in security it was right after it was
2018 because were traveling the globe
yeah and I think we we saw him with the
duffel and we said do you think he has a
gun in there actually was 2017 it was
the year of the breath so was right
after Ty yo
TB so was right after gungate yeah
that's why we were extra
excited yeah extra
titilated I have a picture with him I
have to find it probably could you found
it in the past have I I know I took it
on Snapchat and I think like my my
caption was T like so search t on your
phone oh that's an amazing idea the
phone search feature is getting
incredibly smart oh my God so funny of
course I was looking for my meatball
recipe last night I searched ground
chicken and it didn't come up I have a
million screenshots of like various news
stories about tar elmusa I have an Uber
where my driver's name was tar obviously
I thought that was
funny it is funny
um oh I have a covid test result that I
screenshotted and the physician's name
was Dr tar um no okay I mean it it would
take me a while I have to go you know
what year you said it was
2017 oh my phone only goes back to
damn no it doesn't
sorry I will find
it and I oh wait here wait where no we
in
Nashville I'll find it and I'll post it
on my Instagram oh by the way there's
another article talking about his
steroid addiction which um he started
taking steroids after facing testicular
and thyroid cancer and the steroid that
he was taking was testosterone on top of
that he was taking HCG injections every
day because he was told to so yeah the
addiction was
to testosterone steroids damn yeah this
why you got to read people's book it's
so true people are layered
some would say are you ready for our
next story you mean am I ready to move
on from a story I've waited six years
eight years for excuse me no I'm not but
I'll find a way yeah we could always
come back turty to your show don't worry
I will yeah are you ready for our next
story then yeah I don't know how to
start the next story without asking you
profusely okay um no just like a next a
segue in general oh my God just it's not
about this particular story because this
is a caus to celebr Christen news check
lands an NFL deal after creating the
viral jackets for Taylor Swift and
Britney momes Christen new has landed a
licensing deal with the NFL the
representatives from the NFL confirmed
to page six style that the organization
has penned a licensing deal with the
designer as first reported by sportico
Kristen who's married to Kyle yusek
signed a contract with the football
league for an undisclosed amount that
will allow her to use NFL logos on her
designs okay so I think a lot of people
were hoping that this would happen we
spoke at length about how it would
really in the NFL's best interest to
really capitalize on the moment they're
currently having with like young women
um and give young women an option for
like sports clothing that aren't fugly
sorry there's nothing out there for
women that isn't like truly embarrassing
and heinous and if there's one person
who could do it it's chrisan use Che but
in order to legally sell and distribute
official merch with NFL logos team logos
team colors you have to obtain a license
and the NFL is like notoriously stingy I
think there's like five companies in the
world that have the license and her
getting one is huge I wonder what she's
going to do with it I wonder if she's
going to continue to make like bespoke
high-end one-off pieces if she's going
to start like a direct to Consumer
retail company I don't know but this is
huge this is huge and a huge step one
small step for Kristen yek once large
step for womenkind yeah but I would also
like to see her have a line with NFL
shop yeah I mean that I think would have
been like the more obvious route for
Kristen specific like longterm this is a
better deal for Kristen that's true
that's true also Zach told me CU I was
talking to Zach about this last week how
Kristen like needs or the license
whatever he said that Aaron Andrews has
a women's collection with the NFL shop
and like that is their women's L women's
thing like oh women you want clothes
like we by Aaron Andrew and I hadn't
looked at this stuff until now cuz he
was like you should look at it it's cute
stuff is it some of it some stuff is
cute and like you could tell they're
inspired by like the
reworked type
of uh apparel official women's gear at
the NFL shop they have like denim
jackets with the logos on the back like
it's it's it
covers what I'm seeing I don't know if
this is Aaron aers I'm just looking at
Women's it's [__] Haus but do you see
the ones with like the lace Co like no I
must be looking at the wrong
thing oh here by Erin Andrews oh it's
better yeah it's better and I'm I'm sure
maybe there's stylish Clause where like
they actually couldn't do the same thing
with Kristen because they do it with
Aaron Andrews it's not it's not amazing
I can't lie it's better but it's not
great it's not amazing but Aaron Andrews
isn't a clothing designer right and
Christen use Che is so I don't know if
she's going to like start raising money
if she's going to start a whole ass
company but I think by next NFL season
she could be up and running and given
the momentum like this is huge like she
could really like be at the beginning of
starting like a billion dollar company
for real
yeah it's it's like kind of the most
amazing thing ever I wonder if her and
Taylor have chatted because as far as I
know Taylor didn't order Britney did and
you know Kristen being The Savvy
businesswoman that she is threw in a
jacket for Taylor oh you think now I the
way I I mean you might actually know
Actually I don't even know how I know
that I might have just made that up what
I think happened is Britney's worn the
things a few times I'm sure Taylor was
like I like your code and Britney was
like I'll get you
my friend Christ makes them she would
love to make you one I don't know why I
just assumed that like Britney ordered
and she threw an extra one in the Box oh
that was Kristen's entrepreneurial
spirit that was like here's one for
tailored yeah I I really don't know why
I why where I saw that or if I just
actually made that up I feel like
tailored complimented Britney and
Britney was like oh I'll get you one
that's classic friend stuff all the time
I'll hand it I do that for you all the
time if you like something I'm like
turty I got you
oh by the way have I gotten like a bunch
of
boxes not a bunch I have like so much
stuff arriving at your home just the one
stuff of like the The
Outfits but then have you opened any of
it yeah it's in your room okay but like
I have something coming don't open it
who's it addressed to me so don't open
any of my boxes okay just like tell Zach
cuz he just opens boxes willy-nilly
around here I have to tell Zach you live
with him can you tell him and why would
he listen to me not you I'll forget is
the problem that's the problem here but
come to think of it like a toaster DM me
she was like you have to get this for
Jackie and I did oh and it's addressed
to you yeah but I cannot actually I
could just text him right now since
we're like doing admin in the middle of
the show I want you to open it on air oh
wow please it was like from an Instagram
ad I know it's never showing up check
order
status sign in I oh my God I totally got
scammed what is this website oh my God
so exciting I ordered some kids clothes
from a website that looked fake but it
wasn't and they came and they're super
cute okay they're making me log in but
like I don't
have oh I totally got scammed I took all
the bank and the toaster who scammed you
maybe it was her company her heart was
in the right place you don't think she
set up a fake website to trap
you I don't that's good
you want to hear something so funny
always so I I need to check the dates I
got an I guess I had totally forgotten
but in October of 2022 let me get you
the exact
date what are you going to wear for the
Super
Bowl like pajamas I kind of need Kristen
you to make me something oh my God I
mean it is a dream but I feel like she's
like kind of busy oh yeah she's probably
making outfits for all the Wags for the
big game at least she has two weeks this
time usually she only has one week
so October 6th
2023 I placed an order at the Taylor
Smith merch shop for 1989
merch one week ago I got an email that
my order had
chipped well that's and it still hasn't
arrived but people know when like that's
her thing like she I had completely
forgotten she doesn't produce until
after the orders are in it will be 3
months yeah well that's like that's good
makes me feel good about if our merch
ever takes a little bit me too our merch
takes like two to three weeks which it
says on the site and sometimes I'm like
oh I wish we could do it faster
obviously but like Taylor's over here
making me wait three months for like a
$300 order I'll survive it makes me feel
better it makes me feel better too are
you ready for our next story can I alert
you some drama not ready always okay so
it's so funny because we were just
talking about this a few days ago about
how Tik Tok and like the the nature of
Tik Tok celebrities so interesting
because you really every now and then
somebody blows up and what you do we
were saying last week with those five
minutes we'll set the tone for we said
Alex Earl did it very well and Emily
Maro really felt like she didn't really
capitalize on that she kind of just
wanted to live a quiet life and be like
a major content creator which is great
she did her first like
businessyoutube
God people are
roting why so it's it's an extra- large
canvas tote okay it's
$120 oo and it comes in two colorways it
doesn't really have any like you know
special features you know storage cup
holder whatever A lot of people are
comparing it to the LL bean bag that
everybody uses for their Farmers Market
which I think cost $19.99 so people are
rioting against Emily R Rodrigo Emily
Rodrigo what's her name Emily Maro um
saying you know not only is this out of
touch she doesn't care about her fans
cuz she's not like the type of Creator
she doesn't like respond back to people
they're like you ignore your fans and
now you're making us pay $120 like no
one's making you do anything calm the
[__] down and this conversation that's
being had now people are like well why
would people support Emily Mao when she
doesn't interact with her followers ever
like she ignores her followers that's
what people are saying now and this is
like all because she released a bag and
I just think it's like the craziest
conversation being had like she really
doesn't owe anyone like a response she's
just putting out her content and again
like she released a bag would I
literally ever spend $120 on a bag that
looks like that no but if you're a
really big Emily Marico fan like that's
what it's worth to you I guess and no
one's forcing you to buy it just don't
buy it just don't buy it it's nice
looking and by the way both colors are
sold out well yeah but then people are
like well it was sold out so obviously
you know we don't care that people like
well she could have just said it was
sold out like everyone's being really
trolly to Emily Maro it's cuz they can't
get to her and they're mad it's by the
way they can't get to her and I I pray
to God she doesn't respond like just
keep being your unbothered queen yeah
and it's like if you're not going to
respond to like everything up until this
point all the positive whatever don't
respond now to the negative because then
it will just breed more negativity
because they're like oh that's how we
get your attention yeah just keep doing
you Emily Maro yeah also like Emily Maro
is not LLB you know she doesn't have
access to the type of It's Made in the
USA and like yes $120 is a lot but I
imagine they're they're not costing you
know 5 cents to make like in this
economy like that's what things cost now
120 yes she's probably making a nice
little profit but it's not like the way
it used to be where like a canvas bag
cost 10 cents like she's trying I know
she's making in the USA she's making you
know ethically sourced Queen so that
plus the economy canvas plus you got to
think about the economy that's what you
know the economy Stone wash 10 oz brush
canvas 12 oz duck canvas Basin handles
100% %
cotton made in California by the way
that's also like with our merch prices
have went up in like the last couple of
years and it's not because we're like
greedy we want to make more money that's
literally like everything's gone up
things cost more now things cost more
now so like that sucks inflation
mhm I do miss the days when we could
sell a sweatshir for like $50 2 plus two
equals sock round here so 2 plus 2
equals crew deck and the cost of aad
it's staggering what it cost to make a
boot these days
it is and you know what war is hard war
is hard life is war the Lebon is a m the
life is a war ain't that the truth now
I'm ready what number story three you
and you better you better get ready oh
my God okay I actually think if you have
something to say maybe you should say it
now and you should say it well because
there are hundred million doll podcast
deals up on the table oh go Jason
baitman Will Arnett and Sean Hayes's
smartless podcast is going to SiriusXM
for $100
million now let me tell you why this is
so interesting and I chose this story
one I love to you know monitor the
podcasting lscape I really really do
especially as it pertains to Smart list
but two is that you know these once in
a-lifetime podcast deals we hear about
them all the time obviously Joe Rogan
$100 million Spotify 60 million caller
daddy they're once in a lifetime you
know you get them in like your set this
is smartless is second big deal they
sold to Amazon three years ago for 80
million between 60 and 80 it was a
three-year deal the three years are up
so now they got another deal for 100
like when we were speaking of jealousy
jealous yeah this is wild it's also good
to know the deals are still happening
cuz I think there's a lot of discourse
around will Spotify keep pay well
Spotify is done with those deals yeah so
whated they've released armchair expert
they've released Emma Chamberlain and
it's not a um
performance it's not because those
podcasts are failures it's because those
deals accomplished what they needed to
accomplish they spent like a billion
dollars over the course of a few years
to get people listening to podcast on
Spotify they accomplished that like
people are listening now they don't need
these all these Spotify exclusive
podcasts like they accomplished their
goals oh I don't do you know that for a
fact that that's no that's what I think
I just feel like companies don't operate
like that where they're like this is
enough for us I feel like they're not
done until they have 100% market share
so I feel like the investment versus the
return on investment the numbers didn't
math oh so you feel like it was a
performance thing yeah not that the
shows didn't do well enough I'm sure
they did really well but just that not
well enough to justify these
numbers interesting also Spotify had
major layoffs last year like I don't
think it's because they're doing so oh
we hit our goals oh that's actually fire
point I don't know and I feel like they
had big layoffs in the podcast
Department I do feel like it's easy to
look at certain shows and see if there
was a payoff like I feel like Joe Rogan
that was their biggest investment 100
rumor to be $100 million I think that
probably is paying off in Spades yeah
and you can it's pretty visible on the
charts like he's sure he's if he's the
biggest show in the world he's going to
be the biggest show on Spotify when he's
only on Spotify but it's like 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 no but also like you're still
hearing about the show in the Zeitgeist
I do feel like when armchair expert went
exclusively Spotify I stopped here in
about the show yeah which isn't
good yeah but I think that podcast is
just so
big I I don't know I I don't I don't
know enough about it or its listeners
now let me say back to Smart list am I
jealous of the 100 million you guys have
no idea however am I jealous that we
started a podcast with two people and
not three so that if one day we got a
major payday we have to split it three
ways cuz let's say now they're all
getting 33 million and they all live in
California very high tax they're getting
15 that's insane and that's over three
years this is a three-year deal so 5
million a year okay I'm jealous making
no money I'm not
jealous take it
back no I'm cracking up yeah okay
poor it's let is poor party it's giving
poverty
lwn that's how you can make yourself
feel better but it says to me tury we're
in the right
industry keep working hard yes of course
of course but now I just okay now I'm
like comparing there's money in
podcasting by and that's like look Joe
Rogan got the same deal 100 million he
keeps it all for himself like that's
insane no and I think there's elements
to Joe Rogan's deal that people don't
know because we don't know how long his
deal is for he does still have ads on
his show he's making it's way more than
100 million I agreee I agree but it's
just interesting also Joe Rogan doesn't
seem like the sort of girly who's like
oh here variety here are all the deal
points of my deal I think you know they
just worked with information they could
get but they don't have all the
information that's a actually a really
good point I always find it really
interesting when people do big deals
when you don't find out how much the
money is I think that's a so much
smarter like who's trying to get robbed
and B it's nobody's business and see
it's usually because it's a lot more
than people are speculating like it's
cuz it's kind of go to share yeah it's I
I agree the deal the deals where you
don't know or it's like rumored even
that old Amazon smartless Deal between
60 and 80 like when there's a vagueness
to it fascinating yeah and when when
it's when the number is
outright 100 million like the Serious XM
deal that's because everybody approved
it like yeah we want everyone to know
it's 100 yeah like you have to you can
it's your choice to keep that number
private or not so public it's because
the the talent the smartless guys wanted
you to know yeah it's almost like they
were talking to us directly oh yeah it's
like oh you said smartless is overp
party we'll show you smartless is not
overp party yeah 100 Mil you say 100 Mil
I hear five totally and that you assume
that they split it third third third yes
I was going to ask you okay I was going
to ask you that question too but it's
equal work like every they each pick
guests they each interview Jason is
definitely more like the captain of the
ship but that's no I that's just like a
personality thing yep I I think it would
be insane if they weren't it
insane and maybe like trouble at
smartless yeah and I think like they
proof is in the pudding they've been
this Trio for many many years and
they're still having that success and
you really could not have stable success
like that if there was an imbalance in
the Dynamics
totally I'm so happy for them so the
deal keeps the podcast widely available
but brings perks to Sirius XM
subscribers and could possibly encourage
more to join Sirius XM like you know you
got special [__] over there Sirius is
now like entering the podcasting game a
little late but um as like the biggest
radio company on the planet they should
have been doing this a lot sooner but
now they have like a full ass podcast
like team Department Etc yeah they also
have other podcasts such Just Jack and
will bad dates and owned I think they're
part of the smartless
world oh smartless has other podcasts or
SiriusXM does oh SiriusXM has a million
podcasts yeah they it's me
tin let me see what this is just Jack
and will who's
Jack me Jack Just Jack and Claude Just
Jack and will with Shawn Hayes and Eric
McCormick oh I guess that's their
characters spin-off spin-off yeah so the
smartless worlds it's snn it's giving
good guys probably podcasts yeah
smartless News Network
snn anyways congrats grads it's always
congrads nice to see people doing big
things in the world of podcasting and
that's just titilating news it is
titilating news and we need to work
smarter
tury we need to work smartless
sir
yeah so feeling motivated hash motivated
hash hustle hash the grind never sleeps
ever # smartless is not over party we
spoke the grind May the grind may never
sleep but I do yeah maybe we'd beat more
successful if we could get up earlier
actually maybe we would if we like got
this podcast out at 8:00 a.m. should we
should we try it one day and see if our
numbers are like I like that idea or try
it we'd have to try for like at least a
week I
think yeah let's do let's do it I ha
waking up early like what time do we
record then 6:00 a.m. that's ungodly
maybe age actually six is better for
me well let's discuss offline
we're working smarter not harder weing
harder we're also like we're still
people we could by the way by the way by
the way night before yeah if I had a
studio in my house like you did it would
be much easier but I could come here at
night okay let me see what time all
these stories went live so tar El Musa
was 7 a.m. today we would have missed it
that's the thing like news comes out at
like 5: in the morning show GMA chrisan
you check we would have had smartless
came out yesterday or Monday oo late old
news uh this next story came out this
morning and then okay but think about
nights like Sunday
night we were up what till 11 watching
football what we record at midnight
maybe not on Sundays
right we'll talk about it offline yeah
okay let's get into the rest of the
stories that are brought to you by
Taylor Farms Claudia I am brought to you
by Taylor Farms Taylor f Farms chopped
salad kits deliver the freshest best
tasting salads to eat at home or on the
go across North America Taylor Farms is
a family-owned company on a mission to
create Healthy Living Through fresh
delicious food mission accomplish Taylor
Farms their chopped salad kits AI boring
in every bag with over 30 flavors so I
feel like salads in a bag they get a bad
wrap and that's because other companies
be they they're putting crap in this bag
like it's not fresh it's not premium
these salad bags first of all I have
like 15 in my fridge right now I'm like
in my salad era and I'm very specific
about salads especially like the level
of chopped the level of chopped Taylor
Farms salads in the bag are first of all
so good I love their flavors of course I
love the Caesar also love the Citrus um
they're chopped like I want my salad to
be mulch like I want it so tiny it's so
chopped they have such good flavors I
had two yesterday one for lunch and one
with my dinner I sent you a picture of
my lunch salad it was the most gorgeous
thing like I look like a Kardashian
eating salad if you want like perfect
salads at home all the time like this is
sh Chang my life they are pre-washed
pre-cut and they're ready to enjoy so
sometimes when I'm like so hungry
feeling like an animal I will eat it out
of the bag but if I'm trying to be like
a nice girl I'll put I play oh my gosh I
played mine I did the dressing drizzle
tury I was living large purchase Taylor
Farm's Cho salad kits wherever you like
to shop it's available at all major
grocery stores just a good thing I'm on
my health Journey always good to have in
the fridge it it could be the whole meal
you can add protein to it or you can
just put it on the side for like you
know you have a meal a nice little side
salad that's what I did last night I
made meatballs and I had my tailor Farm
salad tailored Farms I had my Travis
Farm salad tailored Farms okay speaking
of tailored you guys things are there's
drama is there like sort of Universal
Music looks set to take all of its songs
off of Tik Tok after a breakdown in
talks over the social media sites
licensing agreement in an open letter
the group accused Tik Tok of bullying
adding that they only wanted to pay a
fraction of the rate offered by other
platforms for the catalog of millions of
songs however the Chinese own social
media platform called this a false
narrative so while Universal claims a
social media platform with more than 1
billion users accounts for just one% of
their revenue the move will result in
many of Tik tok's users favorite artists
and sounds being removed so seven out of
the 10 top 10 artists of the year are
with universal and their musics would be
coming off of Tik Tok including tailored
Swift Beyonce Drake the weekend Bad
Bunny
Ray
now you Tik Tok as of this morning I
believe all of you Universal music
groups music is off Tik Tok like it's
it's fully started Tik Tok released like
a shady little statement being like
we've managed to come to deals with
every other record label I don't know
why umg is being difficult umg is the
biggest um if I had to take a side I'd
probably side with the artist I do
understand Tik Tok saying like the value
of the Tik Tok is a promotional tool so
the value of that that is worth
something in addition to like us paying
you like a streaming licensing fee but
at the end of the day like you're using
this is a billion- dollar company Tik
Tok
using copyrighted music and like you
have to pay that's the law and also if
Tik to didn't have access to all of this
music the app would be crap it's true
actually they need the music too and
what makes Tik Tok so awesome is that
you can use any sound and and like it's
started with like dancing and lip
syncing so true without music what is
Tik Tok I know without Tik Tok like what
how are people going to promote music
like for real
reals reals come on over
shorts like this is I feel an avoidable
thing they really need to figure this
out like this is bad for everyone it's
bad for Tik Tok and it's bad for the
artist at
umg yeah but the artist I think umg and
the artist will be okay and I think Tik
Tok will be okay and maybe Tik Tok
changes now and maybe we do get more
unknowns maybe it winds up being good
for smaller artists s who AR label this
this story if I was an independent
artist like I'm jumping for joy like it
obviously creates more opportunity for
somebody who's not locked into a deal
like this but like the way the app
exists now it's like they both need each
other Universal Music Group they need
Tik Tok the artists need even the big
ones like you need Tik Tok it's a it's a
part of like the ecosystem now and Tik
Tok needs that music who needs who
more I think umg needs Tik Tok more I
think Tik Tok needs umg more oh okay cuz
there are like other
promotional way they could go back to
the old ways of you know of doing it
there are other social media platforms
who are willing to play ball yeah and if
it's all the
music I do want to say though and I
would be very curious if there was like
some data released Tik Tok in the last
like month or two has really kind of
changed their MMO they're they're
becoming like a a shopping platform and
all of the content there's a new tab
they're really boosting videos that are
selling products because you know you
can have a shop on Tik Tok you can sell
other people's it's like almost like an
affiliate you make commission and it's
really [__] annoying like it's
insanely annoying all the content I get
served now I had to block the the
hashtag hashtag Tik Tok shop because
every video was trying to sell me ramen
noodles like insane annoying and people
are really annoyed about it because
that's not what people come to Tik Tok
for and it's it's like a big change that
hasn't ended up being good it's like
annoying and between that and now losing
like a huge music provider like the app
I feel like is really changing in a bad
way I think that's good I think it's
good too like Tik Tok had too much of a
you know choke hold on the culture for a
while and they're and
it's to our detriment to to the
detriment of society of course like
people are Glu to their phones and stuff
but just the things that have come out
about like the things that TI to
platforms no and the anti-Semitism and
horrible the Osama Bin Laden like okay
yeah maybe we should take a step back
from Tik Tok if that's where it's led us
it's very so I think the app
self-destructing love that for them I
kind of agree like I love the app more
than anything but I agree come on to
real tur Loop if you love something set
a free yeah are you ready for our fifth
and final story that's going to lead
into our TV recap which is really just a
TV recap yeah Lala Kent thought Rachel
Levis AKA Raquel was going to go bag
groceries and wouldn't have reached out
if she had a crystal ball so we saw last
night on Real Housewives of Vanderpump
Rules um that's pretty much what the
show's turned into yeah Lala reaches out
to Raquel because she feels bad after
what she saw on the season but then Lala
went on watch what Happ Happens Live
last night looking unbelievable yeah I
couldn't get enough of her face and her
hair I agree her face looked amazing and
her hair the style she basically she
basically said like she reached out to
Raquel because she felt bad but then
Raquel ended up going on Bethany's
podcast and like saying all these things
and then launching her own podcast where
Rael I mean Lala thought like this was
going to be the end of rael's public
life and so she wanted to like her well
and just like make sure she was okay but
it turned out like that that wasn't the
case so she kind of regretted that whole
thing anyway yeah and I think we all
thought that after she went to the
mental health facility that she would go
back to her hometown and be Rachel and
lead a life outside of the public eye
because clearly the Limelight and the
this lifestyle was not good for her and
it Le led her to make really poor
choices so yeah I have a lot of thoughts
on the vaner pump rolls episode I do
feel
like beginning filming before sandal
returns from his
reality TV show competition filming was
an enormous mistake because like say
what you want about him the show is
beyond uninteresting without
him I didn't need an episode without him
to be honest like there really wasn't
much to even recap but I do Wonder CU
this thought did cross my mind and I'm
curious what your thoughts are did you
feel like la la reaching out to Raquel
like Raquel was you know she said Raquel
was on her heart and she just wanted to
reach out and check in um do you feel
like that was genuine or that was you
know laa kind of seeing after the Vander
pump rules reunion a lot of like the
conversation and the public opinions
kind of turned being like damn like have
we taken this too far sounds like roel
maybe like could do something dangerous
like do you feel like that was lala
trying to mitigate any sort of criticism
or she genuinely felt that way because I
really was not seeing the comparison
between Lala's situation and and
Raquel's situation I understood the
comparison but even if it was LaLa being
swayed by the public opinion like maybe
it took the public being like whoa for
her to be like whoo and it's not NE she
doesn't seem like the type of person who
does things so that she could be
America's sweetheart and the fan
favorite because she doesn't do those
things she doesn't do anything or say
anything that she doesn't believe so
even if that's what influenced her
coming to this decision I don't think it
was in any like inauthentic way and
maybe it just in a positive way
sometimes it takes seeing something from
the outside but I do think that in that
moment where she was like I only have
Tom and if I turn against Tom I have no
one I think that there was something
that she related to in Raquel that she
hadn't experienced up until that point
and when she described it I could
understand when she's like I know that
feeling okay um let me ask you another
question who's your least favorite
person on the
show well it's Tom sand ofal well
honestly he's not even my least favorite
like he's at least entertaining like no
I can't listen to him speak it's It's
upsetting to me even before Scandal like
when he's like doing the most and the
most ex oh by the way before Scandal
like could not now it's like fun to
watch someone self-destruct and be so
delusional and narcissistic for me it's
Tom Schwarz I can't stand this man I
don't think he's funny I don't think
he's cute I don't think anything he does
is kitchy him being like hey Ariana
welcome to Tom like I hate this man and
I just like I want him off the show like
that's how much I hate him
yeah yeah and it's like he
never took accountability for himself
and just never like came out of santal
shadow and now he's like no I'm not
sandal don't put me in a shadow it's
like you're the one who stayed there
you're the one who tied yourself to him
and made every decision and let your
marriage go to [__] because of him and
now you don't want to be associated with
him no and I think a lot of people are
like damn Katie so mean to Schwarz but
like I understand her on a deep level
like imagine being married to that and
then finally being free and getting to
like say everything you've ever felt
yeah and now he sees what you've been
trying to say for years and it's like go
away loser completely agree and it's
only because things turned out so bad
for you it's not like you came to this
realization on your own on your own and
it's like even when Tom was doing the
things that have gotten him Tom sandal
when he was doing the things that have
gotten him canceled for lack of a better
word Tom Schwarz knew about them and he
ate it and eded it's not like the wool
was pulled over his eyes and the friend
that he thought he was wasn't who he was
he knew I also do find the Dynamics of
the female relationship so interesting
yeah CU it's like they're all close yet
they all have underlying tension no and
like for those four I feel like for so
long Ariana and Shea were best friends
and also laa and Ariana were so close
they literally like had an affair so
when they sat at the table and Lala was
like I feel like you know so weird I
feel like you don't like me and then
when they were basically saying like
it's it's Katie and Ariana and then
Sheena and laala like I was shocked but
no and then it's also Sheena and Katie
and
Ariana and no I'm sorry it's also laala
and Katie have a best friendship and
Sheena and Ariana those are the closer
ties and then secondary no I feel like
they were saying primary was Katie and
Ariana no like live together and like
are such close mom friends I feel like
the tightest in that group right now is
actually she and laala right now yes but
they've also had issues remember with
the yeah Lala's very close with Sheena
and Katie and Brock and sheena's very
close with Ariana therefore they're all
close but there are these compc two
strains of Katie and Sheena who kind of
beef and laa and Ariana who kind of beef
which I didn't know yeah but it's all
there like last season
even it they've had they they there are
like high highs and LOL LS with them
yeah it was like kind of a boring
episode like I don't even know what to
recap like yeah it was just sort of like
setting the table for the season it was
nice to see everyone but I really feel
like the way scand ofal like we were so
caught up in it like I have completely
come down from it and it's kind of true
weird to watch some of the stuff and
what I found Most Fascinating is Ariana
said that Tom wanted to buy her out of
the house but she doesn't feel like she
should have to move what I didn't know
that either oh and I wanted to say like
I have sympathy for like their living
situation being not ideal but their
bedrooms were unacceptable I'm sorry
what grown people can't live like that
their bedrooms were unacceptable the
texting through the assistant but Tom
saying that he wants to buy her out
kind of CH everything I thought the
problem was that he was refusing to buy
her out and refusing to sell the house
leaving her no option her only option
would be to sell half of the house a new
roommate for Tom Right which is like
who's going to not a real thing
yeah if he wants to buy out of the house
why wouldn't she leave why would she
want to stay there I mean I guess it's
like it is a good investment that's the
thing they bought it like a while ago
and the valley so popping and they're
actually really responsible for like a
lot of like like the valley Village
becoming the Cool Young area it's
honestly actually I kind of feel her
like why should I
be rid of this decent investment that I
worked hard for many years ago I
actually kind of feel that so he should
buy her out at the price that it's worth
now oh I guess yeah and to have your
life back and the peace and instead to
be living with the person you hate most
on the planet yeah and I guess like you
wouldn't want to stay there because it's
filled with such bad memories filled
with bad memories you were staying there
where you were in a couple and you were
settling down and and now that's not
even your life anymore like yeah why
would you want to be there I don't know
I you couldn't like as long as he would
pay minimum what she put into
it minimum and what it's worth now yes
we could argue over they could probably
reach an agreement on a price there's
you couldn't put a price on the freedom
yeah get me out of here I am looking
forward to him coming back like I'm
sorry he is the most interesting po
person in the show right now and I did
think this was going to lead to Raquel
coming back that Lala sending the text
that was my my only suspicion was like
lala was sending this text because she's
like oh this Show's boring we need
Raquel back they need something yeah but
Raquel's not coming back she didn't
answer the message yeah and I I don't
think that she should honestly I'm not
well if she's going to live a life in
the public and do a podcast she should
be on the accompanying reality show
that's
fair but I'm not even I'm not really
desperate to hear or see from her like
to me Tom is more interesting he's so
delusional he's insane he's got it's
almost like I we've always said he's
like this horrible narcissist but what
has happened to him in like the last
year is jaw-dropping honestly and to me
he's the most interesting person in the
world right now like everything he says
is insanely stupid insanely wrong he's
the biggest narcissist on the planet
like it's fascinating to watch yeah
let's see what how he's going to play it
right oh my God long episode today yeah
it's late oh my God we got to get this
episode up if only we woke up at 6:00
a.m. you guys thank you so much for
listening to the toast M Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so watching us on
YouTube please to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so Spotify itun Stitch
public radio I Radio cast walk all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find us the CH five star Vi about how
beautiful standing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow bye love you
bye